[Música]
e aí galera que atingiu o planalto bom
vocês mas só isso mas cada vez que você
perguntar se a gente está bem e você não
faz se você está bem está ótimo mas se
começar o vídeo antes de começar a ver
eu quero dizer pra você que é de campina
grande que dia 21 eu estou aí você quer
de joão pessoa que dia 22 eu estou e
você quer em fortaleza que dia 28 eu
estou aí todas as informações desses
shows no primeiro link da inscrição do
vídeo tudo bem com vocês
ótimo som do melhor que a da concelhia
que na boca do meu clube que eu fico
triste às vezes porque as pessoas têm um
preconceito concurso em um grande
preconceito na hora que alguém fala
culpa wiecko luiz sai bosta sai merda
gente não é assim você tem que dava
louco você tem que dar valor tem gente
que não dá mas tem gente que já dado
mais valor nesta passando vergonha
às vezes você pensar mas é um mero órgão
escrito hamas é um mero algo que você
não deve dar valor mas vou ficar com
vocês como eu que é muito importante na
sua vida é muito mais importante do que
você pensa o seu coração seu coração
seguro em falar não vai faltar só quando
chegar em casa o seu pulmão e isso seu
pulmão ele segura uma parada
respiratória água para funcionar que só
quando passamos a mão pé num existe
agora você mora no bairro mais longe que
tem na cidade você tá no centro mas
aquela vontade aquela pontada linha
assim votar de cagar você está a
quilômetros da sua casa o curso seguro a
pé em casa o cosseguro a gente o que é
forte e é porque numa área não tomou e
pronto e ele não faz isso por mim ele
faz isso por você e o cura e dá
segurança e tem aquele povo chamado com
familiares o carro em casa sua casa
perto da família ele não deixa você
carrega na casa dos outros porque um
cunho legal a boston é uma bosta e
traiçoeira às vezes você vai pagar na
casa do amigo e falei não vou ficar aqui
são a claudia leitte é uma preta gil
gravou kaká que só o neymar vê um vulto
cidade ficará 15 vezes aquele
senão 10 que eu chamo de bosta vaivém
você dá descarga desce some você fica
feliz agradece a deus a 2 segunda cabeça
na volta mais ou menos assim vamos dizer
que eu sou a bosta
logo ela volta então quer que seu corpo
mas ele só deixa você carrega na sua
casa fale poupado constrangimento você
deve ficar na casa do amigo pedro taques
vai pra casa voado você não sente nada
conta segurando mas a partir do momento
que você dobra a esquina da sua casa ele
começam sinalizando que está chegando
gente escuta uma conexão wifi com seu
banheiro funciona até como gps perder o
seu bairro dar uma voltinha começou a
piscar a pé de casa você entra dentro de
casa bem seu pai dessa moça no meio
chupar entra no banheiro fecha a porta
trancada a porta cento você pensa que
vai estude em merda ou espera 123
segundo a box aí gente o scania ano
passado e esse é o seu banheiro eu tenho
é muita tecnologia de valor hoje porque
eu já fui com você e eu já fui
preconceituoso mas meu corpo me deu uma
lição sim me deu uma lição dolorosa eu
desafiei meu a botar uma coisa grande
dentro não não é isso está pensando
quando era criança meu pai o dia os pais
da gente gosta de comprar a fruta verde
para botar dentro de casa né
aí quando amadurece e distribuir toda
família todo mundo come só que eu mundo
cão que era eu olhar aquele caixa de
boneca e falar assim mesmo muito doido
dois começaram a comer sabão é feito do
jeito que ela tá pra quê meu deus gente
meu cu trancou de tal maneira que eu
sentava no vazio botar força e botar
tanta força que falar não vou virar
super saiyajin vou transformar nível 3
que não sair nada aí vamos fazer o quê
tomate via pra que ele odeia de novo
gente eu vou contar pra vocês que eu não
saí desse banheiro aliviado
eu saio em depressão pós-parto a
primeira coisa que eu pensei em fazer
assim que eu terminei carga foi chamar a
partir para cortar o cordão umbilical
por que meu deus do céu parecia um
menino tudo aquilo acumula hoje se
transformou em uma só e doeu muito por
esse valor o seu corpo e de volume
também se você tiver gostar de civis e
por favor clique gostei vai ajudar
demais no facebook vai ajudar demais
clicar em curtir essa postais la marca
seus amigos
aumentá la em baixo e assistir civil
também e se você quiser continuar vendo
os meus carros minhas histórias aqui no
canal no youtube é só se inscrever aqui
no canal que sempre vai acompanhando
beleza
muito obrigado a descer e subir até aqui
valeu e à noite
agora vou mandar cagada